So a few years ago,
I had to make a work trip to Stockholm.
And because it was the school holidays,
I needed to take
my two kids along with me.
And at the time they were 14 and 12.
Anyway, my local colleagues,
needless to say,
were really very supportive.
And in fact, knowing that I do research
on language and social class,
they'd also clearly enjoyed
arranging to put us into a hotel
belonging by a large Swedish chain
called Elite Hotels.
So on the day that we arrived,
we checked in and then we made
our way straight up to our room.
But as soon as we crossed the threshold,
my oldest son declared
with genuine frustration,
"But this isn't elite."
(Laughter)
And I was a little bit surprised,
but also kind of really curious
to know exactly what he meant.
So I sort of pressed him,
and he quickly explained to me
that the room was just
not big enough to be elite.
(Laughter)
So in that moment,
I realized that my son had already learned
two really important lessons
about everyday language.
First, that words are very influential,
but their meaning can often be slippery.
And second, that the language
of superiority and comparison
can lead to disappointment.
But it's tough.
Nowadays we're bombarded
with messages about excellence,
distinction and success,
and we hear voices telling us
you should be a top student,
or a winner, or a leader,
or preferably all three.
And it's this that's started me
to think a little bit more
about what's going on here.
How do we manage this?
Because all of this leads
to a profound sense
of what the philosopher Alain de Botton
has called status anxiety.
And for me, this is a kind of anxiety
that arises through our constant worry
about not being good enough,
or always needing to be someone better,
or to have something better.
But the reality is this.
Not everyone can be a top student.
Not everyone can be a winner,
and not everyone can be a leader.
By the simple law of averages,
most of us have to live
a life more ordinary.
Well, it's for this reason
that I've started to rethink
or perhaps even reclaim
the notion of mediocrity.
And I've even been challenging
myself to consider the possibility
of embracing mediocrity.
Now, obviously, I understand
that mediocrity has a bad reputation
with sort of connotations
like average quality
or not very good.
But the sociolinguist in me insists
on digging just a little bit deeper,
maybe listening to some
of the word's origins
and unearthing some
of its other meaning potentials.
In actual fact,
the word mediocre has its roots
in the Indo-European "medial,"
meaning "middle."
So essentially then, mediocrity
is just about existing
between two extremes,
hence middling or average
or otherwise unexceptional or ordinary.
So, as I say, statistically speaking,
life in the middle is inevitable
and unavoidable for most of us.
And in fact, it seems to me
that the middle is not
such a terrible place to be.
In fact, it's quite
a privileged place to be.
It may not be as good as being at the top,
but it's surely not as bad
as being at the bottom.
And the trick, I suppose, is to learn
to recognize our mediocrity,
or at least our averageness
or our ordinariness,
without allowing other people
to make us feel like failures or losers.
Needless to say, this is quite
a bit harder to do than it is to say.
And I think especially so nowadays.
When we’re surrounded by these voices
pressuring us to be the best
and to be better,
we find ourselves, I think,
in a world that is bombarded
or confronted constantly
with what I've come to think of
as a relentless language
of superiority and comparison.
And it's as a sociolinguist
that I've been tracking this language
for quite some time.
And in this work,
what I've been trying to do
is show that this is not just
a relentless language,
but it's also often a very sneaky,
surreptitious language.
And it's with this in mind
that I want to just share with you
a couple of my favorite examples
of what this looks like.
These are my two favorite case studies.
And the first of these
is the word “elite” itself.
And this is a word that circulates
everywhere in our lives,
which is, as my son
discovered in Stockholm.
But take a look at a few of the many
examples that I've also been collecting.
So here we have an elite grocery
store in Denmark,
we have an elite nail salon in Seattle,
we've got an elite phone shop in the UK,
an elite electrician's
in Switzerland, actually in Bern,
and then an elite pastry shop
or bakery in Poland.
And all of these, I can assure you,
appear in decidedly non-elite spaces.
(Laughter)
But when I say that elite crops up
everywhere, I mean really everywhere.
(Laughter)
I promise that after this talk,
you are going to start noticing
elite everywhere too.
(Laughter)
And I've never been quite sure
what we're supposed to think
when we're being told that our pickles
are elite or our tissues.
What exactly, I wonder,
does an elite condom offer?
(Laughter)
And I don't know about you,
but it's going to take a lot more
than the word elite
to convince me that a urinal
is in any way prestigious.
(Laughter)
But the use of the word “elite” like this
is a very, very common
language game nowadays.
We see this word attached
to all sorts of goods and services,
kind of meaning everything
and nothing at the same time.
And in some ways I suppose
it's all perfectly harmless,
a bit playful even.
But I can't help but think,
and in fact, I genuinely believe
that these ubiquitous,
constant appeals to eliteness
are trying to persuade us
that superiority really does matter
and that status is something
that we should be thinking
about all the time.
And these little one-word messages
also suggests to us
that superiority is easily obtained.
To be very clear,
the language of superiority and comparison
is really good for business.
All of these relentless
little one-word messages,
and ones like them,
are trying to keep us
aspiring upwards all the time.
And if we're aspiring,
we're also acquiring.
In other words, we're shopping.
And for this, they don't even need us
aspiring to be the best.
Just aspiring to be better
is often enough.
Which brings me to my second
little case study.
The one little, one-word message
that I'm talking about
in this instance is “premium,”
and a good example of this appears
in the so-called premium economy services
offered by most major
international airlines nowadays.
And it's no coincidence
that premium economy
can be more profitable for airlines
than business class.
But what's interesting about this
little one-word message
is that it's precisely not
about being the best.
Premium is all about having
just a little bit extra
or a little bit more,
and especially a little bit extra
or a little bit more
compared with others.
And to be sure,
marketers know only too well
that people will pay good money
for feeling better off.
Even that is when this comparison
doesn't make us feel
very good for very long.
But the most striking thing
about the word premium
is that it really crops up
in way more banal spaces.
And I'm offering you a few more
examples than before,
because I really want to impress upon you
just how far-reaching
this one-word message is.
So we have premium chocolates
in Sweden (not Switzerland),
we have premium chips in Spain,
premium coffee in Australia,
premium tomatoes in New Zealand
and burgers in Denmark.
What we seem to have in Switzerland
are premium cigarettes
and premium barbecue charcoal.
Elsewhere, we've got
premium puzzles, premium haircuts
and my most recent encounter in Poland,
premium baby diapers.
(Laughter)
Again, premium is just about
having a little bit more
or a little bit extra
compared with others.
And as I say, these comparisons
are usually built on illusions,
and these comparisons just
don't make us feel good for very long.
In fact, all of these silly
little language games
are a perfect example
of what the famous sociologist
Pierre Bourdieu called symbolic violence.
And in a nutshell,
this is about the way that we allow
words to manipulate us,
even when it's against
our own best interests.
So while social comparison
may indeed be in our nature,
it invariably leaves us feeling insecure,
inadequate, unsatisfied.
There will always be something
more or something better.
And there will always be someone
better and better off.
So the question for me is this:
how can we avoid doing
symbolic violence to ourselves?
Well, personally,
I find myself returning once again
to the possibility that mediocrity
might hold the key or a key.
Now I understand that embracing mediocrity
might feel just a little bit extreme
or uncomfortable for some people,
which I think is fair enough.
But the point is really just
about coming to terms
with the inevitability of our averageness
and maybe finding a way
to find the value and perhaps
the privilege in being unexceptional.
And for this, we've got to keep
reminding ourselves that it really is OK
not to be the best.
And it's certainly OK not to always
want to be someone better
or to have something better.
But I think that nowadays,
especially when we are surrounded
by this relentless language
of superiority and comparison,
it takes determination
and it also takes real courage
to be ordinary.
Thank you.
(Applause)